and not having a dad and all that stuff
and being misled from the beginning and
that really happened a chance so the
misinformation I was destined to into
prison I was destined to end up on drugs
night and day I remember being on that
PW T school bus used to dread going home
you know have to take shortcuts and walk
through well he's you know the
domesticating remembers me actual jump
it on me not having no father did you
know they died me to protect me had a
brother and when it was time for me to
learn to take my uh my driver's test he
didn't he didn't he wasn't there to show
me because he didn't care and when I was
think 16 and I had to do my purse some
job I didn't I didn't get through it
because I didn't have nobody there to
show me and I'm 53 years old and I get
to watch my nephew take his little
brother from from graduating high school
to Community College you know I called
Mike I caught my own nephew Chris saying
Chris with you see I mean I'm taking
Isaiah the arm registered to roll in
school I said were you there for his
driver's of his first of all driving a
thing at school to see yeah uh that was
gave me some pointers and all that kind
of stuff but he had instructor Whittle I
said what about his first summer job you
say yeah I helped me fill out the
application and that's how I learn do
you know what my nephews and I had two
older brother you know growing up I was
poor black and in real trouble I know
that from earlier on just for my
surroundings I remember being bused oh
I'm sorry I brought myself Central Los
Angeles and I remember being one of the
first people that were bused back in the
days to the values sampling on the
valley
I remember going the Larry elementary
school that he loves to furious I had a
Korean friend named Chen killed
I had an Ecuadorian Fred look like John
Travolta with beautiful spirit kindred
spirit and um I had a
a black friend and Chris I'm irritating
beer just chubby do solvent assault all
over in Dom they asked me to spend the
night at their house I spent the night
at my Koreans for himselves
in getting to the door he says they
tickets LD she's wound up take off your
shoes before okay no problem and I
remember just laying in that bedroom and
they're soaked bed wishing they could
adopt me like they did in Diff'rent
Strokes Todd bridges but for the life of
me he asked me a few times hey would you
let me come down you know in its finale
with you I said no not now maybe next
week next week but the real reason was
being in his house and being in my house
he wouldn't have seen no roaches you
know they can have TV and you see them
running up and down the wall or see a
mouse run right in front of you and
stopping and do his thing like you're
not there I felt ashamed I felt
embarrassed and I feel anger you know
not having dad and uh
just for being just for him man for
being black man poor and in real trouble
I just couldn't fathom man that coming
home I remember taking Chris about Chris
now it's a spin and we spin when it's
been a week and sever Sonny's my black
friend from the valley in junior high
and not remember as we got deeper I
remember we were walking up to mop up
the port in the building but I stayed in
and he looked and I saw this look him
over his face and I said I know what
should they did this took him upstairs
and too different for my mom brother
sister and you know he was just like
whoa you know he just couldn't believe
it
he couldn't believe somebody was just
poor he didn't believe somebody who beat
us for this is down and out this out of
luck you know and he put on a good
cheering everything but after that he
didn't talk to me no more
just like he just disappeared in a smoke
so when we graduated from junior high
that was it
I never saw him again he never called
you know you never kept in contact with
me or nothing he just and I live with
that every day I felt the same way he
did
and two cousins I love both from the
same equally what was good what was bad
one was one can fight real good and he
had that that / son of that that looking
at you know I want to be just like him
as far as learning how to detect myself
being raising a you know single parent
household and I had an other cousin that
was real let the letter and I want to be
more like him because he was nicer to me
than my other cousin look at my other
cousin we should go to the movies
instead of ping downtown we will go to
the tower and we will go to the alley
and we'll climb all the way up to the
top
well are we it climbed all the way down
and I'm talking about 15 16 story side
man and I'm gonna be so scared to death
because I'm afraid of heights
I'll just be looking right where do
these what it was cold upper got the
handrail the hand grows okay you're
climbing the outside of the building
climb the outside of the tower on
Broadway they have movies on Broadway
7th the Broadway and the tower and I
forgot the other one but that when we
couldn't climb over today to have no one
no heroes in the bed but we had to get
on top of the trash can
I remember six of us and I'm looking up
I'm like oh my god I can't do it for the
life of me I stay up I won't I'm gonna
get on Cup I won't get on top of her
call her a truck who it I saw afraid on
you back then because my cousin I want
to impress him I did it I don't know one
time I was climbing a pin on myself at
the same time I was so scared
that's not a bear sand that's just the
truth but I did it for him to show him I
was like oh let's just you know just
lawyer man just lawyer and just want to
just you know just wanted to be anybody
but me nerves a mama's boy skid her own
shadow
that few friends growing up but like I
said always just want it I just want it
to be like everybody else
I always feel different I've always
dress different I remember the night I
was 15
pump rocket just came out I listened to
the Sex Pistols and about the Hollywood
and I stayed gone for three days I met
these I was in Hollywood walking down
the street and walking down the side
street and these guys were no you know
um by the side of this building they say
hey would you like something you like a
beer ss you're okay
I said what's that it's just a club come
on man it took me in the club I'm saying
all these people with the spike here and
all that stuff I'll go downstairs I see
four youngsters 13 14 years old this is
an 84 and all that said Mike my foot
once was tapping and my and it's been on
ever since I've been listening to punk
rock since 1984 and I still have a a
comb playlist that I listened to at the
LA Fitness downstream my point is when I
got down there in and I saw the spikes
and it just it just ripped it it arm it
just did something to me just it just it
just made me you know just took me
somewhere I never thought I'll go and um
I stayed gone for days I didn't call
home we were in Hollywood we bomb
changed we drunk beer of marijuana we
stayed in abandoned buildings but let me
know I had to get home to go to school
but you know what I came back with a
mohawk I got teased I got bullied but I
cut it until it was time to go to school
and I said where I was growing up I was
just different you know what Michael
Jackson came out I had to look be have
to look jheri curl print same thing at
the time you said about that I think you
know that the button-down shirts with us
but damn pants gives me their arm the
doctor is in PE loafers and stuff like
that and I remember I should be a mod
hat the long church coat with all the
buttons I had some 501 jeans and had
checkers on one side and check his own
other with Mitch met all stark commerce
all stores you know that was me and I
had all kinds of different hairdos and
Dom I met my mom sin you know what she
said when I look back at you growing up
she said man you everybody saw race
because you didn't like you didn't look
you don't look like stupid at it you
know but he's always compliment you and
just be you know Jeffrey then the rest
of the neighborhood kids she said you
got compliments oh I've never seen ever
told me that being but she said in
retrospect said I people's like means
some special about what Eric some
special about him and I just didn't
believe it you know so all the
information I was given by Y wrong
information how awhile I had to cheat
out of steel how to fight
Rob and all that kind of stuff and other
cousin strictly sports and I remember my
cousin graduating from from high school
and going to college and he was saying
he was in uh in town so he would come
and get me on the weekends take me to
the campus and had me spend the night
and he would take me to all the drills
you know I went to be just like him he
was a wide receiver and he was gonna be
the first one in our family to go to
college and make it in the pros and I
wasn't following his footsteps but what
happened was
he didn't um he didn't he dropped out of
college up to the second year and he was
telling me he said here if you know what
he said man I don't have nobody to talk
to this granny my mom your mom
there's nobody in any area that's ever
been in college so they really don't
know where I'm what I'm feeling what I'm
going through and I didn't know at the
time either but I'm glad he confided in
me I'm glad he told me that it meant a
lot to me that he told me to it's he
didn't have nobody because nobody was at
that level but he gave it to me and I
appreciate that and I will always
treasure that he try to push the
Benefield teams after he dropped out of
college and the last team I think he
trotted for was the San Diego Chargers
and he didn't make it
so he feel like he let the family down
cuz everybody was you know Thomas he's
young he's gonna be the one he's gonna
be the one to do it you know he's gonna
be the one you know and when he didn't
he made a decision to marry a size
school sweetheart
and move to Texas
this is right before the crack the gangs
and all that
I said please take me please take me
with you he said I can't man I said well
why all that a sudden why all of a
sudden why now just off the boot but why
wait of Texas he said to city says you
have to do he just said he just said he
just had to go up the hill but many
years later when we talked he told me
why cuz he feel like he let everybody
down
and there he went one day he was there
and I think about three days later my
cousin was gone I love my cousin I love
my I love and I love my cousin he said
you know what Eric he says only one
regret man I didn't invest in you
I shouldn't invest in you when I didn't
make it because you were better than me
and you weren't taught that you just had
that natural ability man I went through
the school you know about Pop Warner and
all that kind of junior high high school
so you didn't but you just had that raw
ability he said that's my regret I
didn't invest in you when I didn't make
it instead of leaving so when you left
here come crack here come gangs and just
so man just it was just like wow I
didn't do the game thing mama's boy I
jumped and all that kind of stuff so
come from school junior high leading to
high school you know I'm going to I'm
being bused to the to the valley and the
real areola diamond valerio elementary
school for to the to the high school
then ice high school and now remember
just leaving the neighborhood wrong way
out there and seeing the difference in
streets cleaning the houses and
everything and I remember being on a
vent eyes and I will leave for lunch and
go to the song little Wong little while
sandwich shop when they have some
videogames in there and up love
centipede a stone again my plate up at
us 40 years old never played another
game but Center people love it I
remember in the neighborhood I'd be at
home it's the kiss I hate Eric the guy
the store owner around the corner wants
to see you so I'll go around there he
says hey ma'am we thought this guy from
four blocks away he wants to play your
centerpiece and if you win I'm gonna
give you the 2-liter soda the big bag of
chips in the king board you know what
leave me about 20 kids in there watching
me and I said the guy from another area
played me because I was always the first
three on top of centipede it was my name
all raised and I always played at that
store and I remember stores is being
packed with kids watching and I'll be
jurist and sweat on the game for two
hours cleanest want to look I'm back and
forth but two hours and boots playing on
our salts plan sweating in a shop owner
loved it now I'm like and I didn't I
didn't even realize that then you know
that the store was packed where kids
watch
so I didn't do a the game thing cuz I
was a mama's boy scared of my own shadow
but I would experience but some drugs in
that hole and I told myself I'll never
forget I told myself 1450 I'm gonna try
everything at least once man [ __ ] who
did that [ __ ] min you're on to that like
a badge of honor because it turned out
to arm you know just just here we go uh
marijuana loved it alcohol not too much
to cure about it I just said the
drinking when it was time to go to clubs
and stuff like that rush to go to a USC
to cap up to the sorority houses and get
some of the treat before just a bust
from neighborhood one bust down the
street then you know over there by USC
and have the time of my life and my
remember didn't go to the neighborhood
parties what my friends because I'm
dangerous it was my neighborhood you
know
so it just hit me the courage man just
to be okay with just me because I never
felt okay with me
I never feel that God belonging to
family never I just didn't I went
through self-deception self-hatred
couldn't stand being black because what
was depicted on TV just wasn't the same
reality that I was living I'm looking at
different strobe so I'm like oh man why
can't I beat our purchase looking at
good times love good times because it
was always a struggle but the difference
between good times was the Jade James JJ
had a father and I didn't I didn't so
we're Thomas left Newton stepped in and
my introduction person crack
I said I tried to think once and I would
do anything for my family even though I
knew some information was being shared
we was wrong it didn't matter I love my
cousin but my family's not gonna hurt me
to be the last ones that hurt me and the
two men that were left well Thomas one
of my cousin left was my brother and my
cousin and I didn't get I didn't get
what I needed to be a bit of the stand
on my own you know I didn't know
anything but wrong you know and I was er
I was just scared man I was a scary cat
you know and drugs and alcohol made me
feel better made me feel like I could
like I could be you know and I never
became because it was a reality so I was
stuck in this this mind set under the
influence and whatever it was at the
time PCP
crack cocaine marijuana always me
running beer oh shot here who once
I'm not gonna do remember the guy said
to me don't don't don't don't tell your
mother
cuz just take your breath get at my mom
and I'll be up shits Creek please please
I'm gonna do this but never and I said
okay I kept my word until now but no
names but I never forget walking to the
store and I felt like I was walking in
slow motion with the mi myself we
stopped at the light and all of a sudden
I just vomited doctor what yeah I never
touched it again after that that was my
point experience um I smoked it by deniz
him think I had bought 15 rehabs behind
me how's that there's a Jewish program
it's - - token blacks me and another
brother
so min wondered brothers he had out you
know we just we just clicked and um he
uh came to the house cuz I did I did I
was a week from six months graduation he
disappeared yeah but I had to stand by
so he came by my house he sat in his car
and we talked you know he said put it on
there and he showed me how you doing I
did it and I got sick to the stomach but
not like I did off of young introverted
way but sick nonetheless and I remember
being in that in that program and how
comfortable it was at how roomy and I
was testing it stars the same and um
when you come up from this month I'm
down here from New York
my mom said I'm from Jerusalem I'm from
Israel what I came all the way from this
room this is Joe's program mm-hmm
how much you pay I already say about
thirty thousand I was in New York I feel
thankful and just being around that and
learning the few things and having
somebody invest some time in me open up
my mind so what could be rather than
just us being second is this
south-central kind of mentality you know
just rap only in just what I thought I
knew you know just my little what I had
is far as blinders I didn't see nothing
but my experience and being in a Jewish
program open up me to other people's
experiences and how far they came from
and how we all has something to comment
you know so I remember being turned on
the crack first time I take a hit loved
it
still in love never will be the same and
I knew it I knew in the depths of my
soul that I was really headed for
something and I know it was gonna be
nothing good and real fast
I became a thief a liar a cheat and
homeless within three years of being 15
years old to 18 I was homeless at 18
I think I did 19 trips to prison from 18
so I'm 53 now 250 my last one was uh 9
years wit 84 two dollars fifty systems
stuff up the 99-cent store because of my
past history I could have died
but it's busted in disguise but back
then I was just having fun
I was just trying to escape my reality I
didn't want to be me I didn't want to be
in a damn ladder and be in the
neighborhood
I'm going to be anybody else but me so I
took on different parts of I took a part
of my cousin Thomas I took apart million
Todd all these other people that I grew
up that out that I liked and I was I
lost myself in the process it took me to
be 51 years old two polygons see
register who was looking back at me in a
mirror to get to know that person who
was just looking back at your nose
person loves you depends on you and need
you to be there but him like you Lord
you to others use Laurie to the don't
man because he's gonna give you
something
oh he trusted you this to stay in the
house while he was somewhere so you
lured to him to a fault you know he used
to stuff to go to prison and you did
time for him why can't you do that for
you why can't you better lower yourself
because I was never looking in the
mirror long enough to see who was
looking back at me so I was always
running always trying to escape for me
I've got doomed Oh No even though I got
the wrong information from the beginning
I understand that because looking back
in retrospect it's what they were taught
so these they were just giving me what
they were taught even though it was
wrong so they knew so it was all I knew
going moving forward and I got time to
go into prison I think I had ten trips
in and about 15 programs by time I was
thirty thirty one tip no so I'm sorry my
bad about 20 26 27 so man I took a
chance cuz up you know from from being
in prison at et they have we expected so
I'm I'm real big and I'm real strong I
look like drama they called me back then
they caught me on what they call me
back then when I was younger this family
like it see it made you look like a
superhero you know cuz up just and I did
you know tall dark and handsome with
muscles so that was a extra something
that I had you know my favorite moving
forward you know and um it was all about
the outside all about that I couldn't
see past what you saw so how you feel
determined how how much value are placed
on me and on the women that are you know
that I had my relationships you know my
worth was based on you know how well I
mean love to I was satisfied you know
how proud they were to be with me when
we were all you know I couldn't just
factor in just having just happy for me
you know but I always place it on
somebody else's if they feel good if
they have you have said then I'm sad
that my value for me go there my work
clothes Dale if they get upset you know
and when the relationship didn't work
back up my mom selves back and doing the
thing off doing the same thing all over
again so after buh-bye
field relationships about 15 programs
involved nine trips to prison to 16
months four years nine months seven
months violations every time I come on
get me June and I was in June and the
guy said hey excuse me
all right can I touch the earth it's
just all I wonder if he can train me I
said sure
and Elvis I'm sorry I started training
them and he said I like to take some
pictures one day and submit them to
magazines is that think you just might
and what's a sure so I did I did a
couple while I did one more of us I had
a chainsaw cut off lumberjack shirt on
the ladder with the bandanna then the
other one other photo shoot I did I was
like a police officer but the cutoff
sleeves and everything and well she must
later he calls me made the cover man I
was so happy I couldn't believe it
either this world mom what we you make
the cover of a real rugged magazine man
wrote known you know he said there you
know a lot of people read it okay what
kind of magazine it was a gay magazine
what I'm not gay
you don't matter you made it okay I made
it and I was okay with that and with
that we went by different go bookstores
and he said see you see that's you
son get one from here and I get one from
this video store we go to different
stores and system the puppeteer notice
me that's on there I get it for free so
I get 2/3 from this room to from this
one and that home look mom Wow
you make the yes or the don't book
though but I was so happy I passed him
on in neighborhood I didn't I didn't
give a damn about somebody no it didn't
matter to me you didn't [ __ ] out of a
somebody you know I've made my own way
there's something you know on my own
that um that are getting recognition man
so I feel proud I'll give it it doesn't
matter and from mere I got approached
about doing movies I matured old movies
that's how much is it and uh he told me
I said wait a minute
and let me um let me okay I try that I
work so I did two straight movies stop
it and being paid nothing it supposed to
be 250
nothing to me too many men so you just
ran out of money so but I found out the
guy whose users like that
so you even have to pay us it was a ploy
you know gangbang movie so it's like
nine of us and in two women but the
women getting you know good money he's
not you guys didn't get paid because
this is just like an introduction into
the business you know you guys are new
at this so just run get you comfortable
okay I'm cool with that
but after the second time I'm like uh uh
no more getting bang movies I need
something you know I need something
because I've been the first one I did
all for secession you know and came all
four times and I remember being around
these men when it was time to get naked
take her Venice I never forget it was
just a little short kid looks for a
white kid I look down at him I say hey
what are you doing here he said I just
came to enjoy myself man
I said what do you do he said go to
school man you know I said I'm in
college and I said man it take and I
said to myself I wish I could be him his
size stature because he had balls he he
just yeah something I was looking at him
being in this environment little fragile
looking white kid man and I'm I'm
six-two looking like I'm the big bad
wolf now I'm looking at this kid like
wow he's he's you know
so I got all of most of the big dick and
all that and this little kid and I'm
like wow man I wish I could be him to
see what's honest I wasn't so always
terminus in the beginning I'm just a
poor paper just that's it
so it was a ball four of us make that
pact so our women would drive us to the
movie sets and drop itself in wait for
us to get done and we'll go home without
what I women you know where were
relationships before deuce you know that
was you know kind of formed a
relationship with I never looked at my
movies I never went to Boris I didn't do
the club scene where most of them was
looking for that advertise we're looking
to do you know the Dana singing escort I
didn't I just did take my business went
home felt like [ __ ] and smoked crack cuz
I know one day my family was gonna see
that it was more than books that I did
photoshoots but by then the crack hadn't
and I was tired of going to prison and I
found something got to keep my ass out
of prison and it kept me out of prison
seven years doing movies steady income
that's just what I need it didn't have
to rob steal borrow Bagan nothing I was
able to take her myself man and do what
I want to do my way and
I missed a lot of opportunities during
that time to kiss doors are opening but
I feel so bad so hurt about man you know
I'm I'm doing this gang movies and I
hope a woman you know I love women
but I'm doing them but it's hurting me
it's like uh only movie said I'm good
[ __ ] the movie said oh I'm so simple as
like I'm living two lives man I'm Eric
and flex
sometimes I'll go into flex and don't
turn them off sometimes I'm Erica catch
on Erica you know sometimes I got
confused with the tool the percent I
forget sometimes that somebody
recognized me somewhere
hey man I love you oh thank you know
people used to come on visit me from
London it's been out with me - what no
two hours New York flew me out justice I
had no idea because like I said I do my
movie Nicole that's it that knows what
everybody else is just out there enjoy
themselves having a good time
I was office of kill myself while you
were crack cocaine because of the guilt
and shame and one day
here about 6 years of toward 60 movies
around 6 I did about 10 a year and I did
I did him with one top is lower than one
company all those years and I branched
out for a little bit make more money but
I was more comfortable with the you know
this one this one and Dom my little
cousin happened to be in a bookstore
they saw me and rang the alarm I don't
know what she said but it was enough to
have everybody called me like man you
know like I had robbed the bank of
something like what did she say why did
you well whatever you know so I don't
know what she said I never asked her but
I know was something that I think should
put more on attention sheriff does to me
I'm just supporting myself support my
habit I'm staying out of trouble
they're not a prison boo-boo but most of
I'm just I'm just I'm just taking care
of me and that's the way I looked at you
know I'm just taking care of me I never
saw myself as a super store or somebody
but that's how everybody else is looking
at god I couldn't see it cuz I was lost
in the sauce I said my reality was still
self-centered so I'm born I'm going to
these nice homes making a scene and
walking heels with the pool overlooking
the Mel Nezzer Goes Down I met those
kind of helps us and I'm just walking no
drinking water going to the restroom
just you know I'm just like wow see the
Hollywood sign right there oh my god
this isn't crap you know and then after
the shoot I'm back in South Central
feeling like a piece of [ __ ] because
that should be out there not down here
maybe the reasons I mean the people in
the deal with me
so the cat was off the bag and everybody
man just just like the flow walls you
know
amen are you gay you know and then when
I told him that some didn't believe I
didn't give a damn I didn't care at that
point because it was over man
you know the gig was up and I think
about a year after that I stopped there
no more you know everybody was always
lucky than me a surgery a peculiar wave
after that nobody was tripping on the
movies I don't know what he was she said
but it was scepter that just rang the
alarm and everybody looked at me
different from there on you know and um
I didn't care because I have to crack
ass on this man that was my that was my
content I was okay long as they had that
would be good
I didn't care what nobody felt but
nobody said but I did I did and Dom
after the movies I can change the small
crap and not not working in a in the
business and to go back to my old ways
and eleazar nickel and diming
panda at the gas station
still it's a little 99-cent store stuff
like that and want back in trouble run
back into the business cycle real fast
and I remember going I think I'm with
the person there 90 times but I remember
last time I mean first time in the last
time going to prison I remember my first
rehab and my last rehab center but from
last trip to prison I was from another
store $2.00 supported tell us we can say
face cream face cream for a woman at 12
try to stop him oh it's not me distort
they'll end up continuing on somebody
just happened to be at the light
watching as they look in that as a
little altercation as after patient that
out taking place so I've been walking
down the street
take my hat toss it get to the hit the
corner taking a little shirt off toss
around the core continue to walk to face
cream you see all this sudden you hear
this wall scholarship I just knew and on
hey they stopped Earth put your hands up
and I remember to judge on the puppy
printed told me hey man nine wedding
that's it for two dollars and fifty
cents I'm not taking at a 707 which is
at nine with a tea at seven years in one
month I mean I'm 43 I'll be 50 when I
come home can't do it said I'm woman
going oh Lord
and if you go to tell you just sixteen
years so I thought about it mind you I
had my family air my mom my sister my
two nephews and they were always talking
to the just the public friend I had no
idea cuz I mean there for five minutes
um and I'm already customer answer first
first and for so what what happened was
my mother in the district in a public
defender interacting and her swim
pictures up I'm a grandfather first
black police chief of my uncle military
and all that kind of stuff she showed
him a different a different person than
what was in writing in writing was just
a a long history of petty thefts fire
and stuff like that nickel and dime
stuff all drug-related all drug-induced
because I just had to have it and um I
never forget the district attorney came
to the to the holding cells he said hey
man I've been prosecuting man over 15
years that's my job
your mom and the puppies fender take my
eyes off of her crimes cuz that's what
I'm based on what's written in to see
you as a as a person he said I never
came back and talked to my body
he said I'm not going down on the nine
years remaining but what I would suggest
is when you do take do all the classes
that all you can either do if you come
home don't look bad that's the best I
can doing I'm eating two hours deceptor
did not nest it and he left I thought
about so wow that was interesting yeah
just to share that with me he said by
the way he played on he played the tape
and I'm walking down the street he said
oh he just took a survey
oh he took his hat off yeah uh-huh the
only ticket you just put on here oh
we're following on yes yes you see not
out there every time you go to court to
people that you hear now they're up
there remain employed got witnesses I
don't want to give you the 16 I want to
give you nine but if you lose I view the
whole thing because I should've get up
you said I started out for 16 but your
mom the published for public senator
took my eyes off that paper man to see a
human being he said I saw a face in a
long time you're the first one I said
Wow and uh
I took it I take this off I took the
number he went to prison take advantage
of all of the classes stayed in library
stayed and up dropped out at night wait
wait a minute tenth victory yeah I just
disappeared up the tenth grade not
having a dad and all that stuff for
being miss miss Laird from the beginning
and that really having a chance so the
misinformation I was destined to into
prison I was destined to end up on drugs
and I remember okay
anyway take advantage of the class and I
remember some men showing up at the
prison we're talking interacting I'm
saying garlic up chorus of five years
four years three years and came with a
man man oh come on
you won't we don't see what yeah thank
you guys are way up yeah we're going we
don't go go okay yeah I met five men in
prison and we made a peck so it was we
meet in library and chop it up top and
five went home one went home the next
one the next one and it was meat in my
part and he said before he eat he went
he Perot one month earlier he said hey
man I'm leaving phone for you to call I
need you to call me once a week
it's your roll call me of your parole I
know when you parole already but call me
once a week leading up to it I said okay
he said I'm going to be at the training
stuff to get you I see you okay yeah
right now many times I've heard that
I've been to prison what 19 times I had
almost kind of stories man hold on was
dumb table so I'm gonna do that we get
please Yeah right as to watch guys maybe
call to go home
and he'd be petrified man because he had
no clue on where we're gonna go but
you're going to do is they weren't
appear and then have a plan and I didn't
see it until my last time because I was
doing all the things that I was supposed
to be doing necessary to commit to that
and to that I forgot the word but the
setting here's one seven years one month
during that time I got to see different
people seeing what they were doing what
they were weren't doing I didn't have to
ask questions I just watched okay I'm
not gonna do that I'll do this and I
didn't talk the two years the first two
years I was in prison I remember I was
talking to one guy about one of the
classes and a seal walked by Saint
Portis said master first emerged you're
talking a couple years man I didn't even
it didn't even dawn on me minute I
didn't talk the first two years I just
want to be left alone just I wasn't
happy with the nine would eighty uh I
always felt it was too much but it just
turned out to be a blessing in disguise
and I remember I had a GED teacher
scholar you know she call me can report
it see she surfs up with you from a
woman's perspective that's okay thank
you then the sponsors although there was
a women in prison who wanted to see the
men do good the men in prison they
didn't care about us cuz you know
prisoners prison you know it's for like
losers but I notice the women run-ins
staying after work volunteer for the you
know for the the go get the the the a a
panel whatever does toast whatever it
was one on the different classes it was
always women representatives you know
that worked for the prison that stayed
over time after work from 6:00 to 7:30
hour and a half hour 45 minutes for a
meeting you know whatever it was that
one talk
have they had a they had any
Toastmasters the warden but club they
have pre-release and he had someone some
other stuff and the women really
appoints me they really helped me see it
from a different a different angle
because toughen up with the fellas this
is a single thing you know we just
talking the surface things I'll what you
are maybe I was result you know I have
four women there sir just talking to the
did I'm talking talks checking the job
you [ __ ] each other
lying I've never seen that done nothing
but just gonna put it out there they say
hey oh gee what's you here for it I say
my novice out there in the wait I was up
there um
nickel and diming man I wasn't doing
nothing just send away
Nessa God so I'm double just in the way
and when I admitted that I feel that
freedom so year one go by year to go by
your through go by I'm still doing the
classes the library I implement it a kit
let's implement something is to my
program because all I had was my mother
she's getting older it's just on a fixed
income all I've been I've been on on and
off the crack so I did have a woman I
just have the streets all I had was I
have prison and homelessness from my
love affair at mark my love-hate
relationship or crack the solid debut as
prison and homelessness no turn it is no
constant according a woman no job so I
had that kind of relationship and I
loved it and I hated it
can live with it and can live up
daughter
so I remember doing just doing doing it
during the classes I said wait a minute
I don't breed here I don't write poems
on I can't draw portraits I'm not
washing the flows I'm not you know I
said I have to find I'm out of my
mission here because my mom's getting on
their chin she's the only one that's
really looking out for me and I start
training and up within my first year two
hours a day I had where I was training
at seven days a week
different man turn when two days
training another guy two days in another
three days and my mom my schedule is
full so every day for two hours you see
me with the first hour trainer somebody
then you see me the second hour by
myself because that was my time for me
and this one up for five and a half
years straight let's you're a modified
program a lockdown I'm after New York
and if it was raining they didn't come I
was out there I went out in the rain to
sleep it didn't matter and I used to get
referred to when I was you know warning
difficult a train it's a train that's a
trainer and it feel good because I was
doing something positive you know I was
getting accolades and kudos for
something good even in a place like that
with his haters in prison politics in
the the nonsense that goes one everybody
that reached out to me were sincere and
I meant it I remember three years until
what's my incarceration I apologize for
this reentry program so these take me to
a different prison that didn't work on
up the year and a half so they said
would you like to go back to we came
from for the remainder your centers or
somewhere newest and then send me back
to our story I ended up that at the
place where I started and I'm on New
York when they and mob my GED teacher I
didn't know at the time but it said
Portis report to Cora station I said
okay so I'm turning in this guy so I'll
be right back
and it was my GED instructor she said I
heard you were back she said remember
when I told you that I didn't want to
just teach you guys I want to be a
supervisor remember I tell you think you
guys go back to the dorm
to study whatever it is she said I was
home on my laptop taking classes did you
soon know I had the super job to
supervise the job now says I'm she says
yeah I'll have it I'm not teaching the
world she said well I just wanted to see
you I said welcome back man okay
this a week before I went home a guy
showed up from Testim Orange County and
he's been showing up for years and I've
been here for years you know I've been
secretary co-chair and chairman at
meetings you know I'm just I'm just
involved and I remember I'm gonna
secretary and the guy that's leading
meansit's oh by the way
Portis is going home so you guys make
sure that you know know you know say
something
oh just hear him out right Mike looked
the speaker he looked at me and he
started to cry
he choked up I never thought in a
million years that I would affect
somebody like that just by being I'm
just like everybody else seeing the blue
Union or the blue house this and all
that stuff he cried because he was happy
for me getting ready to parole that
listen I don't give a [ __ ] about me
parole and they can care less he did and
it was all the fellas looked at me look
back at him I couldn't believe it so he
talked him start crying and he just and
I said well what would arrive
because everything was everything was
just you know put one foot in front of
the other without even thinking but just
doing and for the first time in 19 trips
I came home prepared and I came home
with a plan
okay how's the last one to leave up to
five dollars to five me a pro got them
Union Station two twos were my friend
was here to get me
I got Van Nuys Hometown Buffet the other
theater waiting with me round table or
we can eat a celebration of me coming
home so a partner was in up so we're
living in up San Pedro soon said let me
take about your mom cells and then you
come out there would mean we do our
thing from there so you're gonna be no
burden nobody you've been gone a long
time and all that kind of sense you have
to be kind of you know we integrated but
you know society and all this stuff you
know I said cool so what about my mom
sells this is you know what son
you don't mind if you don't go to the
sober living but you stay here and help
me up for well I said okay so I went out
to the court told my partner hey she was
um he said okay you know your boy get
stuff off the quarry and um I got a
little stuff it went in and got to be
with my mother man after seven seven and
a half years but what I saw reality was
different than what I envisioned when
when I was in prison just thinking about
you know what my mama looked like now
when I came home she was old and she
couldn't get around like she used to and
it shocked me so much to wear up broke
down I said go in the room and just cry
regain composure and go back to the deal
with my mother in society or everything
else that had to offer me men it wasn't
easy but I had friends that cared and
when a particular cared enough about me
and made sure that I was gonna be okay
that there's nothing that I can tell
them there's nothing you know anyway
both ways
being at home with my mother I thought
it to be like it was before we left but
we changed we both change and I remember
sometimes you say hey man I'm gonna call
your friend if you keep on doing this or
doing that he says hey Eric
your mom said you scaring her she feels
afraid she first fearful man come home
but I didn't see that she we changed man
I thought it would be like I imagined it
but in reality it wasn't we have you
know we have our little disagreements
and stuff like that and I wouldn't talk
to her for two three days man and I'm in
one room she's in another room she had a
two bedroom apartment and she said Craig
Mattson I apologize me I put him if I
did it my bad but we came well do you
well say me anything to each other
that's okay mom you know just keep the
drama down but obviously what her a year
and a half she sunsets you Nate so the
people who come through to check out the
place so I have to leave but they kept
noticing man stuff man things in the
closet and of the room say hey man come
on what's going on okay my son is
working they said well we can't have him
here you know long you have to you know
you can stay two three days you know
whatever I'm soaked okay mom I'll go to
a rehab you know what let me back up I
was going to meetings let me back up
I'll parole the next day I got a
membership at the 24-hour fitness I
started going to meetings and
a year into it I met a girl beautiful
photo rican and bled body off this world
it's just if she like she like party
favors now told hey um you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna program doing my thing
I've been home you know your I got this
much time accumulator
what do you mean party favors drugs okay
man I trippin all that been I've done
that
so we hook up two weeks later you know
she's from New York she's down here she
just got here
she said um at the train station right
so we talked that's what you thought on
that love is just explained to me you
know just got here
New York put okay get all that she said
need time to get situated we'll hook up
I'll call you she called me about two
weeks later now within that year I got
up I got my driver's license that's the
first thing I did and I got it at 50
first time I took the written test I
passed it first time I did the driver
stuff stop half stick didn't know I had
it in me never could imagine ever with
Adam and I'd opened me up to just think
of disguise to let me man there's
nothing I can't do if I put my mind to
it and I never thought like that never
never
but I was gone long enough for my hair
to clear for me to do different things
and it just became it became a rhythm it
just became a natural part of me to work
on the streets practicing this thing it
just natural and within a year I had a
car and I was from from the driver
license to buy Nikora purpose shorts
registration all that and to looking
forward to moving out my mom sells now I
have some real good examples I had good
examples in prison by the women the
women were my mentors because those were
the only ones there that were willing to
stay extra to help us man along through
our years of being in that place I had
one mentor and Street and he showed me
through his actions
he told me his story and how he wasn't
liked and trusted
I'll watched him sober living visit his
wife sleeping on a living room sofa to
her sin does she want him there for a
year because he did something to her
prior to going to prison was the cool
hwhip didn't trust them I'll watch him
watch it is we're dealing with each
other maybe once he's come to my house
my sweetie and what we do is dim with
each other in meetings so I'm watching
him all the time he said if you really
want to know somebody watch him
hear what they say I said okay and
within five months he was back at home
because he showed us why did he were
serious and he taught me something the
same thing and before you knew it I was
somewhere I've never been before
I was I was an unknown territory and I
loved it
I remember relationship I was in it with
this woman I think I was in three before
I met her
and my downfall but the the one before
her she flew me up north to her place
and when I get to her place says the
chest from the nice things he said for
you it's Nike shoes
white Eskimo ice bill thank you shorts
hat she has the nice for BMW
and she have to see hold this position
in the hospital
don't worry about method she painted
this picture I'm like thank you God
thank you for this compliment this is
some oh I don't know what you call it
but she painted this picture and I
believed it and I was like wild man just
like my dream is finally coming true off
the light Todd bridges from Diff'rent
Strokes at 50 that was me not being
adopted but in other words of course
been adopted [ __ ] anything had nothing
worked it tore some things and I stayed
there to one we flew back home float
back up there again for another week
came back home now tourists Thanksgiving
to Christmas we had a two-week thing she
said miss you take wait you wanna come
on early sure stay for two weeks cool
get up there and with the two days she
but she said can we talk to you Eric sit
there's three things there's three red
flares about you you know the work
history education thing and no license
this is before I got my license I had
met her maybe the first time about
summer I got my license within several
months of me being home she said those
three things I said okay she said so I
feel like um I need more than which you
have to offer
I said I'm cool with that she said you
know what I call the airplane but the
tickets are too expensive she said but I
take the liberty of calling Amtrak and
they have some seats available when the
price is reasonable and they have a
train even today I said I'm only being
here two days I thought it was two weeks
you know just call today and it's
sleeping at uh you know 4:30 I said okay
I'll go ahead and
get my pigs and Don going back to the to
the train man she says you're the first
man I've met that didn't curse me I'd
want to jump on me for breaking up
she said why you I said because you were
honest woman you told me the truth I
still ever wanted my whole life I was
just being misled and it just led me to
these places and I've done these things
and I was just destined for this this
this future that had no I had no control
over the surface things no I was the
active participant and everything I did
I knew right from wrong and I know it
was wrong for the things I've done that
the bottom line is what my partner told
me he said Herot you were deals from
some courts early on that you chose not
to play every time some happen you get
your course it's just fold you fold you
fold and now at 50 you missed out on
what you should be did it in high school
college for us to work the relationship
thing and we started in prison me and
it's man 101 so he must've just Sam
wouldn't share with me telling me about
him and vice versa we're just going back
and forth to work before a parole
Weaver that we were there at the same
place for three years but we regained
this just trust and he shared with me
when I came to mommy sit here whatever
you weren't able to do in your 20 30 s
and 40s because you were on crap prison
and homeless you can do I fifty
particular time he says
pick a to Dean's you wondering the 20
that you wanted to do in the 20s the two
things you want to do in the thirties I
have opportunity and take it to things
that really sounded you that you want to
do you can do them too
he said just don't being arrests and I
never forget that and he's still
instrumental you know call me a check up
on me because five of us came home one
fill another one fill and I feel another
one filled he's the only one left
he's only my opinion in there I'll go to
meetings I do my thing are you know I do
things but we just don't have that kind
of relationship that we did you know
it's not fighting them work it's only
one but it's one thing he does is call
me and if he doesn't have the answer to
something he'll call somebody else to
get it Eric
give me a minute let me let me see
somebody a stone so it might know what
you need or what you're talking about
he'll call me back but hey men x4 take
this number down X pursuing so you good
okay nobody never did that for me not in
my immediate family
he's the only one assure me things that
that I didn't know you know he's even a
prison he said you know he'll he'll
he'll show me through his experience and
what it was the first drug his driver's
test his son his first job even in
relationships with women
he's been with the same woman a long
time so I don't need to have somebody
that's not a relationship about
something I might be going through
because he knows he's stealing one but
he always painted the picture so I can
see it but what it was like to be in
junior high
emotionally and mentally high school
four years to college
he showed me do his experience so I can
see it's like looking at a movie I can't
get it wrong because I see it for what
it is so I know what's real and what's
not
real I know real friendship and fake
friendship
I know real love and fake love my role
models weren't cool so growing up I
didn't trust any man I don't want to be
bothered with any men and everything I
did I did even with the movies
I think I'm a [ __ ] up I was wrong I
was doing what I wanted to do I didn't
I've been killed by no other man's
approval validation I didn't want
nothing to do with no man I didn't trust
me in never didn't I said whatever I do
in life I'm gonna do it on my own all
those trips to prison I did it on my own
I didn't mess with nobody I didn't get I
didn't do I didn't gain thinking nothing
I said please just leave me alone with
me - my turn to go home I'll say all the
trouble I sailed away
okay you got that and no matter how many
times I hit my head against that wall
obviously responsible for me and my ex
is only particular it took me a while to
get that I was affecting other people
you know especially my mom was yet
because my my partner she said man
you're like a bill just another bill to
your mom you might think us she's you
know she's lucky if she's lucky she's
looking out for you once every three
months for the package but you're real
you're not an asset you're a liability
yeah it's cool to have that love that
the letters and all that stuff but in
reality man you you're hurting they're
not helping me cuz you're here instead
of out there helping her she's helping
you and when I was whatever day year and
a half I got to help her I got to do
everything just hey son can you should
go to I bought it gave me a real
pleasure to run jewelry stand on that
cheering
just like I'm in a gym I'm still in the
gym seven this week but she's his son
I'm gonna start walking around the
Cornell because I see you do your thing
all the time so I walk around leave you
so just walk around a clinic twice I
said I tried getting a damn Nazi [ __ ]
everybody's not Jim you know Savin don't
don't don't really care that much but
she said I just want to walk just show
my appreciation he said son I'm so proud
of you all the times that we got into it
and you left angry and you came back
good and I never forget when I messed up
okay so okay I got thrown off but coming
home from mom from up north two days to
said to two weeks I'm on Amtrak and I'm
feeling real real sad real bad and I get
a phone call it's my friend oh man how
you doing up there what's going on you
wanna drink the two weeks out man I
guess life is good I guess you're gonna
be moving up there soon you won't be
doing that down here no more and I said
I'm on my way back home and I ran two
down to him you said okay it's okay
now was it but I learned a lesson give
me the truth men don't give me nothing
at all
tough Careca don't come at all you know
be real with me
solemn eat all I ever needed was that
and it took me a long time to to admit
it to myself that's all I've ever wanted
this is the sin I never had it for me I
didn't know how to give it to me I
didn't how to reciprocate it but all I
ever wanted in for all the things that I
missed in my 20 30s and 40s
I can't experience today do the people I
come in contact with do my experiences
what my nephew's I still don't have a
relationship with my brother
want more my strange spot they came back
when I came home said I'm beer pops but
thank you I'll never ask you for nothing
and I mean it because what would you
want I needed you I just want to be in a
position where I can be okay with me
welcome we are right with the good the
bad and the difficult of me and today I
sent me all of me all of my experiences
man you'd have some things I'm not proud
of but hey that's life
you live and you learn so I don't trip
on the past I don't trip on the future I
just try to stay in the moment and a
little bit about the moment is I still
do the gym I love punk rock music I'll
always listen to it until the day I die
but with Spotify I'll push Israel or be
I listened to for an hour at about three
four songs I'll push Ethiopia listen to
a bout an hour get about six songs
uppers Pakistan listen to a two hours
Afghanistan R&B but six days does the
peace
other Spotify has given me the
opportunity to travel all around the
world through the music
I've never had my own place I've always
lived with women growing up from the
forest since I was a teenager of the
first one out the house at 15 mind you
but I've always loved women and if it
weren't cool if it did work back with
moms until that last trip to prison and
going back to her it wasn't a hindrance
cuz I didn't plan on boarding it she
asked me if I was state I saw any reason
why I stayed with my mom when I can roll
she asks me if I wouldn't mind I didn't
want to be no Henderson oh I want to be
a hill I want to be an asset and I had
my own place today 53 years old take
three years to get to our men and this
is just a stepping stone for me downtown
Los Angeles in a small studio but it's
smiling and I had a key story it's clean
I have food look yeah in the gym I'll go
to meetings a couple no other words much
is that used to cuz I went there to just
to you know get comfortable again with
with what was just being home but I
passed the meeting stage to where I'm
just living I wanna live man I don't
want to survive I know how to survive I
I wonder like for flippy been in free
relationships last when I was in didn't
work but that's okay because if this one
thing for sure that I know wears ain't
met going on but the ring and then comes
genome and then me and then whatever
else that comes you know but a surface
of my mom people still see me and notice
me from 20 years ago
I don't live that lifestyle no more I'm
not that person but when when I'm man
when I'm coming from the gym when I'm at
the bus stop hey and we talk it just
brings back you know hey you know this
this is my story Minister part of my
life man and
I have some man tell me you should have
somebody write a book about you tell
your story I never thought about it like
that and too recently because more
people told me somebody need to write a
book and the cool thing about it is I
read a lot of out of our two pieces in
prison and the a real good one was
Richard Pryor
I remember reading his autobiography and
I remember sometimes at night I'll toss
to turn I remember sometimes I couldn't
sleep by something my bread everyone
sometimes I cry sometimes I'll rap I
said Wow a book like that can evoke
these kind of emotions in me that's a
damn good book and then nothing was scar
tissue by Anthony Kiedis this story you
know that goes back to the music Red Hot
Chili Peppers a lot of this those two I
read I read here's twice empty the
king's score it's just you
I just struggles with drugs and alcohol
it's a overcoming you know I'm still a
work in progress man I'm not perfect not
by far but I make sure at the end of the
day I keep my side of the street clean
you know I want to be welcoming I don't
want to walk around with the scowl on my
face with the anger and all that kind of
stuff with my hands balled up cuz you
can't get a damn thing like this but you
get a whole lot like this so when I'm at
the bus stop as big as I am I want my
face to read you know welcome and
usually when people stand by me we just
talk and I love a good conversation
because everybody knows the ear buds the
phones and all that kind of stuff and
nobody's really I told the lady at the
army I went this morning to this place
called the hippie chicken oh excuse me
the hippie kitchen barometer for lunch
and head beans is younger self so I'm
behind this lady we just start
conversing find out she was our
instructor I've never been an instructor
but I've taught about the gym and all
kind of stuff
she said why don't you do it as a now
girl 53 years old I'm good I just like
that this is his meekness now for
but I said you know I'm going to thank
you lady for engaging me I said it gives
me real pleasure to interact with you
just like this I said thank you for
making my day that's what I need today
just something like that
I don't care where it comes from just
that that's enough of me to make it
through today because nobody knows what
I've been through nobody's knows when
I'm going through how would you know if
you never asked
I know but I know if I never asks you
same question so I'm mindful and I'm
always paying attention
check if I can exit how you doing it how
do you know this and that's just why I
met and um man this is just this is just
the beginning it's just the beginning
for me thank you because I know you know
there's some things about what I should
have did back then that I can do now
every day we do those then what they do
want I should've did it cuz now it still
pastas up us a strong possibility that I
can make a lot of money because a lot I
didn't know people are still at 53 I'm
yeah I'm still a man can't believe it
you didn't I'm still the man I can't
fathom that there's better ways to make
money of course okay I hear you I hear
you
but it's just thinking like wow man I've
never solved I never you know it's just
what it is but that's a part of who I am
because people always telling me that
port a part I didn't want to look at a
part that out you know I didn't I
nothing I just didn't I didn't look at
it and now I have no choice but to look
at it because it is a part of me cuz
it's out there for the world to see I
better learn how to deal with it cuz if
I don't address it now you know okay
yeah I'm gonna run in the right
direction
I don't want this thing I wonder one I
don't want to be in denial about any
part of me I just have to set all of me
and be okay with that then I can be okay
with everybody and the road around me to
be a beautiful place of love
it's like Nikki we're okay here's
amazing Thanks
you